meanwhile we're going to go to senator
john tester the democrat from the
beautiful state of montana
he has been leading a charge in concert
right now with
you know senator domanshin
in opposing president biden's vaccine
mandate
push right now for the private sector
senator very good to have you thanks for
joining me
thanks for having me on neil thank you
your concern with the private sector
push comes amid
you know courts now
sort of
questioning how far the president can go
demanding it even federal
contractors where do you and how do you
distinguish
well first of all i mean look i've been
vaccinated my family's been vaccinated
my entire staff has been vaccinated i
believe that people need to go out and
get vaccinated just as the previous two
folks have talked about
but in the end i've heard a lot
from my businesses in the state of
montana and and they've told me that you
know it's put them in a heck of a bind
and so
i think they should have some relief on
the other side there are other
like the health care folks that need to
get vaccinated i'm not opposed to that
at all in fact i think it's the right
thing to do i think it's common sense
neil so um where are we going with this
senator i know it's an up and down
depending on the headline of the day for
example how far omicron goes and now uh
concerns that were raised earlier might
have been misplaced
how do you feel about where we are in
this whole thing
well look i wish this thing was behind
us uh i can tell you it's we're still
seeing uh some economic impacts from
this and some business impacts uh so i
wish it was behind us i think that we've
gotten good news on omicron uh and it's
in what's going on there
but but i would just say this uh
if you're out there and you haven't been
vaccinated man i don't know about you
but i hate being sick and i think that
uh just get the vaccine and it'll keep
you on your feet and keep you able to be
able to work in and and
you know and and not risk potential loss
of life but it's about moving forward
getting this behind us and it it may
always be back in the background at some
point in time but but ultimately get
getting vaccine getting the vaccination
and moving forward and now as we're here
today getting that that third booster
shot yeah i know i'm with you on that
senator having
been vaccinated that i was a
breakthrough case of god again i just
think i'd be a lot worse off if i didn't
have it
but your point is well taken i do want
to get your thoughts on what's happening
at my neck of the woods senator where
outgoing mayor bill de blasio is going
to force the mandate issue
for all private workers
by the end of the year now he only has a
few weeks left in his term but some are
being saying you're overdoing it do you
think he's overdoing
well i haven't looked at uh at mayor de
blasio's proposal but but i can tell you
just generally neil i would prefer the
carrot rather than the stick
and and i think that we're at the point
in time and of our economy and the
recovery and and and things that have to
get done especially with the bipartisan
infrastructure bill that we passed that
we need to pay attention uh to what
folks are telling us and uh and i can
tell you uh
in the state of montana
folks you're saying business people are
saying this you know even though
the owners think it's a good idea to get
vaccinated they're saying this puts me
in a bind so the mandate issue
for the private sector does become
problematic for for business
so let me ask you in your state of
course there's no forcing this issue uh
you know the governor is in fact trying
to woo healthcare workers who feel that
mandates have forced them out of work to
come to your state where where are you
on that
well look i think when it comes to
healthcare workers they need to be
vaccinated i if i and i hope it never
happens i have you end up in the
hospital and you gotta you we've got a
shortage of nurses right now a shortage
of doctors in montana right now i think
throughout the country and so if we're
gonna have these folks potentially end
up getting sick or worse
uh it's important they get vaccinated
besides that they're dealing with a
high-risk population in a lot of cases
that can't afford to to get this virus
senator well i have you here in these
ongoing build back better talks i don't
know where this thing stands chuck
schumer we're told senator wants to get
to a vote before christmas is that
likely and do you get any sign of
movement the same fellow you're working
with on this mandate thing senator joe
manchin whether he's moved closer to a
yay
look i think negotiations go on on all
fronts but i don't think the timeline is
what's really important here i think
it's getting it done so it really helps
cut costs and reduce taxes for america's
families i think that's really what's
important and i think negotiations
continue on several funds working to get
this bill to a point where we could
potentially get it passed before
christmas but i don't think the timeline
is what's important i think what's
important is what is what is in it
all right we'll watch it very very
closely uh senator very good seeing you
thank you neil john tester of montana
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else